il faut qu'on se préoccupe des progrès
en intelligence artificielle parce que
dans le futur proche et même dans un
passé récent la surface artificielle va
transformer la société très profondément
va automatiser beaucoup de tâches qui
sont pour l'instant dévolu aux humains
va transport va transformer par exemple
tout ce qui est transport voiture et
c'est la santé et puis la manière dont
on n'accède à l'information l'amiante on
interagit avec
d'autres personnes mais la manière dont
on crée la création va être transformé
par intelligence artificielle
donc ça va transformer la vie de même
que l'internet a transformé la vie la
voiture le téléphone toutes les
technologies qui sont apparus ces
derniers des soli et ça concerne tout le
monde
je pense qu'on devrait s'intéresser
l'intelligence artificielle parce que
c'est quelque chose qui va changer notre
monde va changer la société qui peut
apporter très probablement une nouvelle
révolution industrielle qui va impliquer
des changements technologiques
évidemment mais économiques sociaux
c'est des questions sur lesquelles
doivent se pencher non seulement les
chercheurs mais aussi le commun des
mortels parce que nos gouvernements ont
des décisions à prendre puis dans les
démocraties on doit réfléchir ensemble
qu'est ce qu'on veut pour le futur
c'est les gens les plus
je pense auquel on doit réfléchir là
dans l'impact au niveau de l'emploi et
les pays qui investissent dans la
matière grise dans ce domaine là
risquent d'avoir une avance très grande
par rapport à ce qu'ils font comme ça va
certainement produire le même genre de
transformation de la société qui est
apparu avec les progrès technologiques
précédent c'est à dire que
la richesse et la productivité globale
va augmenter de nos sociétés par
ailleurs ça va prendre en conduire un
déplacement de certains métiers donc
certains métiers vont disparaître
d'autres vont apparaître
et ce qui fait que c'est peut-être un
petit peu différente par le passé et est
due à l'accélération du progrès
technologique pas nécessairement d'une
seule stratégie ciel à proprement parler
mais c'est l'accélération générale des
projets technologiques du
conditionnement exponentielle le progrès
est donc ça devient plus en plus
difficile en fait au niveau de la salle
des transformations la société de gérer
ça parce que les gens ne changent pas
aussi vite que la technologie ou autour
d'eux efira organisation